well when you are making this this movie
what where did the dog the dog isn't in
the film what uh you had a dog did you
oh no I found a dog on the on the film
okay
it was all I can tell that story
[Laughter]
three legs no they so I was thing at
this sort of go-to movie guy house in
Atlanta where you know when they showed
me the the house they were like you know
Liam Hemsworth and Miley Cyrus just
stayed here so and they gave me one of
these you know thought was untoward but
it was they're very precious about the
house one I didn't realize was that
there's a strict no dogs policy and then
I was going to work one morning and
there's a little dog it's - it's below
zero and I thought oh we couldn't what
harm can it do and I've let it in the
house when it came back from work it was
like a fecal Jackson Pollock it was like
did he have help
how does he how is he still alive and so
then I had to clean it all up and then
I'd hide the dog and I spent like two
weeks hiding this dog and you know when
it was over the last day I didn't know I
was gonna do with it and actually your
driver beau said that his his father had
just lost his dog of 16 years and so
beau took this little dog and he went
and lived on a lake with a hundred acres
and he went to Lena
literally dog
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you